you know i'm going to tell you something
sex doesn't need to be that complicated
ladies
so all this [ __ ] that's that's not
true but okay
something's wrong with you i know
you have to tell me i know i mean you're
a little too into it
i mean at this point in your life just
you know let's have some fun
and that's it i don't want to spend 10
hours yeah we had we had some fun last
night you know it was cool
you know nothing crazy right no we
we were watching tv in bed stephanie was
like laying on her side
so i started i gave her naked and she
was like
just laying there and i was checking her
ass out and [ __ ] and i'm going
[ __ ] man so i started giving like a
massage
so in other words she gets into bed nude
they sleep
naked you don't really yeah ronnie's
naked
yeah that is wild
bearing wrinkles
[Laughter]
and then what happened then i kind of i
kind of like move in you know i get
you know take the old title up close to
her
yeah yeah get up close and dick is hard
and you know i kind of like
slide it in between her ass cheeks and
so you put your whole [ __ ] in her ass or
do you just
like put the head in i kind of i kind of
like put it like
you know standing up like on an
angle like up the whole ass cheek you
know right in
you just took the two cheeks and used
them like two pieces of bread and use
your dick as a hot dog
yeah and then like rub back and forth
you got it
so you jerk yourself off with her ass
cheeks right it's like a hot dog roll
you know i kind of tell you i i mean i
kind of worship ronnie i mean this is
[ __ ]
crazy i mean this guy's 71 71 right
yeah most guys 71 are kind of like [ __ ]
it
it's too much work i'm going to bed
meanwhile the reality sounds to me like
she's
she's probably scrolling through
instagram while ronnie's hot dogging her
ass
no she's watching tv like the other
night sunday night
i don't know i was half asleep and i was
like laying up against her
and then all of a sudden she's what and
i hear this moaning and [ __ ]
it's from not from her it's from the tv
show there's a whole big sex scene going
on
yeah next thing i know we're [ __ ] wow
just like that
boom no no foreplay no nothing
she grabs me and rolls over and grabs me
on top of her and that was it
and then i went back to sleep i was like
ready
you're coming constantly i mean
unbelievable
i sleep in my juices
[Laughter]
that's why it's so great to sleep naked
because like if you do all of a sudden
you get in the mood
it's just like you know there's no
[ __ ] about it you have to rip your
underwear off or whatever
or pickles or some [ __ ] your pickles
ready
my pickle's always ready her ass is like
my fountain to you
you